[Music]
53 seconds of five production logos also
even though most of us hated the first
one except little kids who are stupid
the studio made enough money to bring us
the second one which will probably make
enough money off stupid little kids to
war goddamn third one stupid kids
I'd recognize those low register front
torrents anywhere this is the
Transformers music right Transformers
music composer oh no it's just the same
composer who clearly rips himself off
lovely too far they said I said you said
squirrel formation this unfunny joke
inside the two-minute mark of this
unfunny sequel should signal to the
audience exactly how unfunny and
unoriginal this rush job CGI fest sequel
is gonna be what's this a generic pizza
box was Pizza Hut not up for the skin
flipping like this with a pizza would
100% no questions asked result in what I
call the zhonya pizza where the contents
of the box after tossing resemble
lasagna as much as they do Pizza
slow-motion character introductions feel
only a little bit weird considering we
met all of them in the last movie right
Oh slung around Pizza hanging above a
Phoenix game I'm guessing yeah gets a
whole lot better than this they're
already down there do you that cost
money and all you get forward or tickets
to a Knicks game they saved the city we
should be on the jumbotron not in it
well you're also mutant turtle things
that the human world isn't ready for so
there's that to consider also if saving
New York City got you on the jumbotron
it would be dominated by spider-man The
Naked Cowboy and Giuliani's phony
earnestness one year ago a shadow fell
over our city my favorite part of live
sporting events is when they turn out
all the lights and play a video about
recent terrorist activity sequel
imagines this asshole was the only one
from the previous film to find Fame and
success men's health launched in 1987 so
the 20th anniversary would have been
2007 seven years before the events of
the first film shredder down bring him
to justice
wait that's the story they went with in
the last movie but this asshole did all
the good stuff and that turtles were
happy drug overdose hallucinations and
people believe that ah Megan Fox oh crap
he's not in range but more importantly
what is that witchcraft technology she's
using here are the Turtles live-action
movie saying Snowden was right discount
Tyler pH that really is Tyler Perry
quick at five Shenzhen let's get the
hell out of here pronto as much as I
like to be someone that a girl like you
would recognize so you're saying a
pretty girl shouldn't recognize a famous
scientist that's racist no please dig
out I mean every time he opens his mouth
I'm reminded how much better Jordan
people would have been in this role I'm
a nerd not a geek only a dork would say
that less than nine minutes in and movie
finds an excuse for able to dress like
she's in a horny Motley Crue video also
shoplifting bullshit elevated 3d display
phone displaying both information on
some kind of wireless nearby downloading
nology which makes the entire exchange
some motherfucking bull they still watch
in the Cabal game also fake-ass Ninja
Turtles love of pizza will now directly
impact the supposedly not fake-ass NBA
game and I'm mostly stuck wondering why
they couldn't make a piece of pizza
falling onto a basketball arena look
more realistic I mean Jesus the Twilight
baby called she'd like a realism back no
one in the entire arena noticed the
falling piece of pizza until it was part
of the play Mark Cuban is currently
tweeting about how lacks the NBA is and
sitting rule president on Pizza related
game interruptions also how do you call
a foul on a piece of pizza you call it a
jump ball that's hell
also given this movie setting and
relative goofiness factor where's coach
Whoopi Goldberg or six-man Kadeem
Hardison that was a close call it was
not remotely close actually you four
disappeared and escaped long before
anyone in the arena even thought to
question anyone that was off court I'm
not even positive anyone's checking the
Jumbotrons convenient cavity at all also
rocket skateboards of the sewers also
also sewers that are 95% empty and
scalable as opposed to normal ones that
are easily 50% or more filled with
literal peak water just wanted to be in
the Halloween parade you totally could
and no one would realize you're an
actual turtle just do it
also halloween' parade i've lived in six
states in four decades and never once
lived in a community that had a goddamn
Halloween parade and if your community
does have one just move to New Orleans
and brace Mardi Gras Halloween parades
are for amateurs and suckers plus five
sins for reminding me of Transformers
where do you get the ping microphone to
all street-level performers get it you
know what I don't give a shit this movie
is the fugitive meets Batman Returns
meets a WWE match and I'm 100% not
interested in any of that
what pot and then just move in the
shadows don't you understand judging by
the previous scene I'm guessing none of
it super convenient computer virus tells
you it's erasing your files while
erasing your files a prisoner transfer
routine that requires two dozen guards
with guns upon loading will somehow
later be so amateur as to allow for
prisoner escape this movie's government
goons are not yet proven to be good or
evil but they still travel by tailgating
black SUV convoy just to keep you
guessing - Donnie just luck out and find
a dump truck that said Tartaruga
brothers on the side or did he paint
that there exactly how much gas is being
wasted with these flame exhaust ports
you got 32 counts of first-degree murder
and yet they're moving into the vehicle
with two guards at night go figure
my name is Bebop this is Ross daddy
getting absolutely no backstory on the
fascinating still human criminals bebop
the knock
steady was bebop a musician kicked out
of his new wave band and turned to a
life of crime was Rocksteady a 19th
century bare-knuckle boxer who somehow
travelled through time I want to know
I'm finish it's when I start a beatdown
I always finish this guy's mutton chop
skills or with this pun making skills
The Fast and the Furious meets Street
Hawk meets that scene in cars meets The
Dark Knight prisoner transfer scene
meets get them out of there eliminate
those Turtles how does he know it's the
Turtles even if he saw the last movie
they just got this turtle themed garbage
truck as a gift a few minutes ago why
are they still on the highway take an
exit ramp and find the nearest police
station or a garage and wait for backup
this plan has clearly failed abort
transport mission get back there secure
the prisoners how about you try slamming
on the brakes or swerving or doing
literally anything to make this more
difficult for this helicopter to pull
shredder out of this van their sensei
Strider can't make it to the extraction
point then we bring the extraction point
to him almost makes you wonder why you
even set the extraction point so far
away then eh
it is decidedly not awesome shredder is
about to get away that device is part of
a machine called the arc capacitor what
was the name flux of the Covenant taken
years ago I launched the arc capacitor
to earth dimension Krang is possessed by
the exposition fairy a war machine the
Technodrome aka that a star aka star
killer base together we can breathe the
people of your planet to their knees I'm
interested shredders level of naive day
right here is a thing to behold I
haven't seen this level of blind trust
since I told my dog we were going to the
park and I got him neutered instead in
case it was all all your problems with
those magic ninja turtle defeating gizmo
of weirdness also awesome how does it
work though who is on candle duty in the
turtles lair and how is he so goddamn
OnPoint
you can't go outside you'll be seen they
weren't seeing the last movie criminal
known as shredder escaped police custody
last night Laura Madison paleri was
serving a life manhunt in progress with
the police chief's an expositional radio
montage over skyline footage filmmaking
101 kids shredders the most notorious
criminal this city has ever seen and we
had them discount Laura Linney is right
how incompetent is this police force
anyway wait that's actually Laura Linney
got it here seriously why is this
eyewitness to the high speed chase with
Ninja Turtles involved giving his
official statement in the police garage
right next to his own vehicle this is
some all I care about is the visuals
here this fool is in a windowless
Kubby chained to a desk sweating out
every answer not calmly chilling in
front of his car like this some kind of
police only resource set up here taking
some time off Jones I'm pulling you up
the payroll that guy was on the payroll
I can help you catch these guys I'm from
New York I know these streets better
than anyone right because they won't be
able to find any other qualified NYPD
officers that are from New York that's
officer Jones and I'm gonna be a
detective someday man this movie turned
KC Jones into a total whiner pussy
here's how much Michael Bay influenced
as a producer on this film worked its
way into the actual film I literally
expected this SRT to be bumblebee for a
few seconds even though Casey is not
allowed to work on this case he still
has the files for the escaped criminals
in his car Casey Jones you better watch
your speed
off the walls bebop and rocksteady are
fucking stupid these are the obviously
racist tiny Autobots from transformers 2
of this movie from sheikha I see the
turtles are hiding out in that one New
York subway tunnel that is 10 stories
tall because that's how a practical
subways are built he put me in charge
and shredder secure fingers you are
personally guarding shredder and you
hope to wrest him in the first place the
last movie so blaming yourself for this
is just proof that you leo have a guilt
complex as long as you keep the team
unified you shall always succeed this
was proven false by the 2007 New England
Patriots hey it's the all-state mayhem
guy which I guess excuses this entire
bar from damages for the length of the
film right pay attention because this
moves fast this cop accused this
bartender of selling cell phones to
criminals fine do it even admitted it
but then the cop demands the device the
bartender is using to track his stolen
sold cellphones and he has one I mean
them sells illegal street phones but
then feels compelled to keep track of
them just for voyeurism sake no one 100%
no one god damn the director was like
just pretend you know how to type for a
few minutes I swear I'll make it look
good this will help open a portal to
another dimension whatever dude can we
just get on with it it needs to be
synthesized oh thank heavens just like
Batman in the 60s TV show oh I actually
already have a device sitting here
waiting to do that very thing to this
very kind of thing beeps I gotta get
myself one of these this transformers
character has the same nickname is a
grating North American pop star did he
just hit both those guys with darts from
a single gunshot this man turning into a
rhino somehow does not cause
catastrophic damage to this
glass laboratory now you're up there
somewhere who entered bebop and
rocksteady names on the devices and went
miraculous inside every human there's a
dormant gene which ties us to our animal
ancestors what clothes inexplicably grow
and expand along with their bodies
warthog dick April has somehow been here
the whole time without any person or
camera detecting her
that's an awesome escape out of did she
know this would happen though there's
literally no way she could I guess this
is supposed to be an only in New York
moment but there's a woman being chased
down by ninjas someone call the fucking
cops how the fuck is this not broken yet
hockey baseball what's your name Casey
Jones why wear a mask if you're just
gonna blurt out your name to anyone that
asks or is the film still trying to
trade on the Megan Fox is so hot all men
lose communication skills instantly card
roughly seven years too late the turtles
show up to protect April roughly 37
seconds after the danger to her subsided
but just in time to cock-block Casey
which I guess makes their entrance
hilarious do not eat us we are not oh
this is the first thing the city it
thinks to say to for obvious humanoid
ninja turtles I know you're stretching
for comedy in these films but damn you
never go full I'm a vegan
except for meat and cheese an eggs
this guy's definition of vegan is vegan
Astana tell over there in the purple his
tactical genius who is technically a
genius character introductions 40
minutes after we already had character
introductions Rida pinpoint a singular
isotopic signature I may be able to use
it to track their location this could
literally be Evan backs or gibberish
battle and it would make just as much
sense have forgive me the most
pretentious names ever movie will not
get credit for mocking the
pretentiousness of the Ninja Turtles
names movie will instead get ass in for
even thinking it could get away with it
excuse me I named them
yes pretentiously when you were a
precocious child there is a giant rat
back there for someone who has lived in
New York all his life this is a pretty
extreme reaction to a large rat
Oh giant rat one new guys zum splinter
could have easily explained he was a
friendly mutant rat to the stranger who
knows absolutely nothing about him but
instead decides to kick his ass for no
reason
tcri logo has clearly and objectively
stolen from ESPN so much so that I
wonder if ESPN paid for this for some
reason bebop and rocksteady fucking love
CGI spaghetti though you if you think
this movie is explaining that can't say
more to this to the others because this
is too important
goddammit well I got a big bang for you
King sigh only one piece never recover
that was the museum heist a fart joke
and some light stampeding all these
rotating camera tilts are about to give
me seasickness if there's even a can't
status can make us human or turtles
whether you like it or not somehow they
are both right Raph should care a lot
less about becoming human after all this
time and Leo should care a lot more
about a mysterious new purple ooze that
makes radioactive giant animals into
humans holy this movie is the fifth
circle of hell am i doing with my life
there's only one boat that counts in
this family mine it literally can't be a
Ninja Turtles movie without some
trumped-up Leo Raph dispute which equals
boring at this point an alarm just
tripped at the Hayden Planetarium only
has anyone called neo deGrasse Tyson yet
I'll volunteer
ring ring dr. Tyson a kung fu turtle
says you're planetarium has been broken
into but no I have not been smoking
anything but tonight at least look you
can help me or not
also the turtles have access to a bunch
of notification sensors that they use to
monitor among other new york city a
planetarium because planetariums are
always being broken into and leveraged
for evil because Leo and Raph bicker Leo
decides to bench Raph and Michelangelo
so that something terrible can happen to
one of these two pairs of separated
Turtles and I'm detecting traces of
neutronium the critical ingredient
required for creating control black hole
how the ever-loving good a movie that's
abusive to science ever get permission
to use the Hayden Planetarium is a
location is the only thing capable of
rupturing the space-time continuum oh
they weren't done please carry on
science turtle I didn't realize you
still had more thing to do on the basic
intellect of humanity but portals can
open up what's coming through from the
other side I guess transformers lots and
lots of transformers so you want to
break into police headquarters where the
splinter right now to make scenes have
absurdly like this possible Raph
inexplicably has the blueprints to
police headquarters Tom hello Anthony
right back at ya Carmelo Anthony saw
LeBron and trainwreck and said to his
agent how could I do a super Beiber
that April somehow knew Vern was at this
party we're a defect Quartus 30 minutes
and there's no reason all for us to
travel there together so we'll see you
there arriving separately for some
reason um
police headquarters in New York City is
one Police Plaza and the building looks
nothing like this this is the
headquarters for like the gap or some
granite this is New York City so just
saying police headquarters as a
destination is a little vague though it
does suggest the main Police
Headquarters which this is not what Jack
Reacher say well good thing they knew a
person famous enough to create this
level of distraction because otherwise
this plan is dead in the water
April had to sneak in the front during a
huge selfie distraction but the turtles
got in the building some other way which
also makes me wonder why April didn't go
with the turtles also I just realized
they left will are not after telling him
where and when but never once discussed
the plan he had to guess all this on his
own that he was supposed to use his fame
to create a huge Lobby distraction and
thank God such a stupid character was
able to be so smart for a minute if
Mikey was just going to hop in and use
computers to approve April's license for
entry then why did we need to bring Vern
into the plan the fact that you could
cut this ninja escape fight into either
of the GI Joe movies without anyone
batting an eye is not a complement to
this movie Laura Linney's like yep I'm
still in this position Jade what we just
saw stays in the department the public
doesn't need to know okay first of all
Jade can't help you with the dozen other
cops in the room who saw that second of
all those turtles you saw are literally
now running through the public who will
ultimately see them it's just math it is
all over the police scanner
oh hey splitter remember how you
disappeared in this movie for a long
time allowing multiple decisions to be
made by the turtles in your absence
people fear what they do not understand
and also six-foot freak of nature kung
fu' turtles on the streets of New York I
got something ah
@id you should come take a look at this
cliche though they half-assedly
disguised it half-assedly apparently
Donnie has launched some sort of isotope
signature tracking satellite otherwise
this would not only be impossible but
also simple it looks like our mutant
buddies are headed to Brazil according
to this map you're looking at they're
already in Brazil and have been for a
while
bebop and Rocksteady advise planning a
drinking game where every time Casey
said bebop and Rocksteady I'd have a lot
more fun watching this movie that's not
what happened
that footage has been alternative yeah
perfectly Jesus a magazine cover can get
caught photoshopping on today's internet
you seriously want me to believe anyone
in this movie's reality is capable of
altering video so that it seamlessly
shows human beings doing things they
didn't do without any pixels out of
place not one pixel have we been told
why bebop and Rocksteady immediately
became evil Gophers for shredder after
bee
mutant eyes is the answer just reasons
oh I'm a rhino now no one's ever made me
a rhino before so I guess I'll just do
whatever this guy tells me from now on
have the final piece and I hit him back
why did shredder send bebop and
Rocksteady all the way to Brazil to find
the last piece of the puzzle and also
trust them to bring it back to New York
thankfully for well basically the
screenwriter and no one else the
turtle's plane from America
passes directly over the henchmans plane
to America at the very same spot over
the Atlantic allowing for this aerial
stunt even The Fast and the Furious team
- unbelievable
yes I'm adding 13 sins for the scene
alone why 13 you ask well ok then now
it's 14 any more questions Oh
[Music]
to what degree am I supposed to be
emotionally invested in a fictional
Turtles fear of heights
what would Vin Diesel do never ask
yourself this ever this Rhino who used
to be human has no idea what firing a
tank shell inside a flying airplane will
do this is a kind of witty banter that
makes me think the screenwriter came up
with this dialogue before writing any
details regarding the plane scene
because the joke is funny even at the
last 10 minutes that goddess ears that
are nonsense
cymbals Dennett I already saw the a-team
this plane is retaining plane like
behaviour even without a back or front
not only does this tank still work after
the horrific plane crash but it also
drives very well in River Rapids what
I'd like to see is a movie from the
point of view of the isolated Amazonian
tribes who accidentally stumble in on
this characters in peril about to go
over a waterfall cliche want to put
criminals away not just keep them in
cages um what does he think putting
criminals away means it's way easier to
pick a cops pocket than you might think
well only if you're an average moviegoer
otherwise your pickpocketing was done
from 12 inches away and would clearly
have been noticed by your victim key to
the city you're the fat guy knows the
Falcon has the key to the city but no
idea what the Falcon looks like way too
many seconds of Will Arnett trying to be
funny on a wheeled office chair yeah
we're very near the finale and this is
what the movie decides to spend time on
some mr. bean office bull comic the
Turtles made it out of the rainforest
without being seen found another airport
snuck onto another cargo plane that
happened to be headed in York Galileo
Isaac Newton thief Jobs this movie is
really on Apple stick oh hey we were
just playing Tennyson even though I'm
carrying a tennis racket and my girl is
not we were definitely not having sex in
Central Park just now it's the tennis
racket in my hand officer goes by the
name of Krang I don't know that guy I
hate that guy he do mostly because he's
arriving suddenly at the end of an
already too long movie to further
stretch it out we may be the only ones
who can survive around that portal
convenient atmospheric issues are
convenient the choice is yours
when is the choice not been there
Splinter you can't just waltz into the
movie every half-hour and act like you
have a say in what's happening so
Raphael and rightly complained that
Leonardo didn't get everyone's opinion
before making a decision
destroys the serum that would make them
human without getting everyone's opinion
oh wow this debris is collecting itself
into a Death Star Wow
movie that pump-faked shredders
involvement well now free shredder for
future use later in an even more
juvenile and stupid sequel
congratulations to Jane woo you get to
say her very first line an hour and a
half into an hour and 45 minute long
movie they all survive this yes the good
guys made it through and yes the cops
were all stopped but I'm fascinated by
how and why this facility decided to
position its anti terror pylons in the
shape of a ten pin bowling configuration
who were the ad wizards behind this that
clearly didn't work like a chewed-up isa
cab
we're the best Michelangelo would be
excellent at cinemasins and also general
appearance shaming xxx out of the
shadows I was right
it's a massive weapons system was it
that gave it away when Krang explicitly
said he was gonna blow up the city and
enslave the population Krang doesn't
seem to understand that he's shooting
his own ship they're dead right you
could live a normal life I don't think
giant mutant turtles can live a normal
life regardless of circumstance
it's like the movie thinks it literally
earns points with you just because it
contains lots of landmarks
you
[Music]
the ball I'm Laura Linney and this is
masterpiece classic as soon as the Sun
Goes Down turtle time nitrogen bonds to
oxygen which in turn we're gonna roll in
everything is great I'm doing awesome
[Music]